we are really big fans at our office how
you are a fan of BTS how do we get you
guys together how do we get you guys to
meet
so I'm petitioning to kind of be there
their secret bodyguard I'm currently
doing some business in China and China
is really close to Korea so you never
know what can happen when I became aware
of the BTS phenomenon it hit me by storm
I listened to their music I enjoy their
music j-hope is my favorite just because
he's got a little bit of street cred
like yourself but I'm I really enjoy the
following and the passion they create I
think that that's something special who
are you
do you speak we're going back to the 80s
transformers I mean this is so exciting
being a child of the 80s and it was
awesome to see the set design was so
spot-on everything is so slow and bulky
man we got it good now it is like some
of the touches we need to look for in
the movie I know they they went above
and beyond to make sure everything was
like 80s specific and my character is
really plugged into like the tech of the
era so I got to deal with a lot of
eighties tech which was crazy so that
was really fun do you more like on the
villainous side I can't confirm it
another another confirm or deny okay
well I'm a big fan of John Cena the
actor and we've seen you play tough guy
we know you're really great a comedy
those are the two kind of things you
need to play the ultimate superhero so
in the spirit of comic-con is there any
hero that you would have your eye on oh
you know anyone with a good story and
Travis Nights right a few stations down
and I really commend him for being
steadfast of believing in the story of
bumblebee mm-hmm and I think after
people see this movie a bumblebee will
be in that conversation of superheroes
because Travis has done such a good job
if I was lucky enough to get an
opportunity it certainly would have to
be a great story and and the great thing
about superheroes is most of them are
well-defined characters so they kind of
have good stories